Salut ! Aujourd'hui je suis dans mon Autolib.
Je suis avec Laeti et Eli dont le numéro de portable est dans la description. Je plaisante !
On devait faire une vidéo ensemble, on s'est rencontrés à la fin d'un spectacle la première fois.
Et on s'est donné rendez-vous aujourd'hui aux Buttes-Chaumont.
Et depuis qu'elles sont arrivées aux Buttes-Chaumont, il ne fait que pleuvoir. Alors que lorsque je suis arrivé il faisait très beau.
Depuis qu'elles sont arrivées il pleut, mais en mode mon pote... il pleut !
Et alors, la seule solution qu'on ait trouvée pour se protéger de la pluie c'est de se mettre dans une Autolib. Parce qu'il n'y avait pas de bar ou d'autres endroits à coté.
Et j'ai l'impression qu'il arrête de pleuvoir là ?!
-Il y a le soleil qui revient.
Ce serait tellement merveilleux de pouvoir aller dans le parc, même si on ne peut plus s'asseoir nul part...
Parce que là, avec la buée, j'ai l'impression d'être dans Titanic.
[rires]
Alors on va faire deux vidéos. Vous allez voir celle-ci vendredi, on est vendredi au moment où l'on parle et on se regarde toi et moi.
Et la deuxième vidéo qui sera la suite et qui se passera avec Laeti, vous la verrez mardi à 17H.
En deux temps.
C'est pas trop mal là.
Du moins, pour une vidéo faite dans une Autolib, c'est pas trop mal...
-Tu veux la poursuite aussi ou pas ?
Regardez, on a un set-up de guedin, avec la poursuite et le plafonnier, s'il vous plait !
Vous devez fort apprécier avec nous le bruit de la pluie.
J'ai amené un petit carnet, j'ai aussi mon calepin mais on risque de ne pas assez voir...
On va prendre le grand carnet.
-Par contre moi j'ai une surprise pour toi aussi.
Tu veux commencer par ta surprise ?
-Disons qu'elle sera pour la fin, mais je te la dis maintenant.
Ok.
-J'ai une enveloppe, comme tu aimes faire. Tu connais le principe, il y a une prédiction dedans, on la met de coté, et on l'ouvre à la fin.
Dans quelques temps je vais faire une vidéo sur comment faire des additions instantanées de tête.
Donc on va faire la démo, maintenant, ensemble.
-Ouais !
Prends ton portable, comme ça tu pourras verifier les résultats avec ton portable et moi je calcule de tête.
Je vous fait voir au fur et à mesure les amis. Est-ce que tu peux me donner un nombre à 5 chiffres ? Tu me donnes les chiffres un par un et je les note.
-D'accord et je les note en même temps sur la calculatrice ?
Non, car on pourrait penser que je vois.
-59 342
D'accord un deuxième.
-67 891
On va mettre... 40 657, 32 108... un autre ?
-88 675.
Donc maintenant tu vas faire l'addition de tout ça. Et moi aussi de mon coté.
-Je peux voir les chiffres par contre ?
Ah oui !
[rires]
C'est pas grave... Je vais quand même mettre mon résultat à moi.
Pour moi c'est 288 673.
-Tu m'énerves ! J'en suis qu'à la moitié...
Toi autant t'es énervée, autant moi je suis en stress.
Quel est le résultat ?
-288 673 !
-Il m'énerve !
Est-ce que je peux avoir la preuve s'il te plait ? Montre à la caméra.
Vous pouvez toujours vérifier chez vous. Tout va bien. On est bien à 288 673.
Bientôt dans une vidéo, après l'été, je vous ferai un Master Class sur le fait de faire des additions de tête, très rapidement.
Est-ce que ça t'as plu ?
-Non !
[rires]
Parce que je sais qu'elle est au taquet sur les maths et la logique donc je savais que ça t'agacerait particulièrement.
On va voir si l'élève a appris...
C'est toi l'élève.
-Oui.
Est-ce que je peux lire à voix haute ou pas ?
-Evidemment !
"Fabien, moi aussi je te fais une prédiction:
1) Ton tour va m'agacer."
Correct !
"2) On va se marrer."
Merci la pluie, pour cette bonne vanne !
"Elie, apprentie mentaliste". C'est énorme !
Je vous montre. Merci Eli !
J'aurais pu faire une prédiction, comme quoi tu allais préparer une prédiction.
[rires]
Parce que moi j'ai une prédiction... [rires]
Vous verrez la suite mardi, et moi je vais voir la suite dans quelques secondes. Donc merci à vous d'avoir regardé cette vidéo.
Si ça vous a plu ce qu'on a fait avec Eli, et si ça vous a plu que je l'agace un peu, n'hésitez pas à nous le faire savoir en laissant un petit mais néanmoins très mathématisant...
POUCE EN L'AIR !
Vous pouvez également nous laisser un commentaire, on les lira c'est sûr. Vous pouvez retrouver Eli si vous cherchez bien sur Internet,
je ne vous dis pas où. Elle a dit "on s'en fout", donc je ne vous dis pas où.
Cherchez la Schroumpfette, ça fait un peu matrice tu sais. Suivez le lapin blanc.
Avant de partir, n'oubliez pas de vous abonner à la chaine ! Olala ! Tu es bien plus nul que Jeff Panacloc !
Hein !
Abonnez vous ! Rendez-vous mardi pour la suite, avec Laeti, et sinon rendez-vous demain pour le Master Class et dimanche pour l'explication de tour.
Passez un excellent week-end, à demain 11H.
Ciao !